[Música]
estamos en junio tras una fuerte lluvia
y el cielo se llena de criaturas que
normalmente no esperaríamos encontrar
ahí
[Música]
a primera vista esto puede parecer un
poco perturbador pero para los
afortunados machos y hembras de
solenopsis invicta
también conocidos como hormigas rojas de
fuego es un día de romance
este es el vuelo nupcial donde miles de
hormigas machos y hembras fértiles
llamadas voladoras o aladas vuelan por
primera y última vez
pero incluso para los machos que logran
evitar a los depredadores alados este
apareamiento frenético será letal
y para las hembras fertilizadas su
trabajo tan sólo dará comienzo
habiendo asegurado un suministro de
esperma de por vida de su difunta pareja
nuestra nueva reina ahora debe comenzar
una nueva colonia por sí misma
descenderá bajo tierra buscando el lugar
adecuado para construir su nido lo
idóneo será que encuentre un suelo fácil
de excavar como tierras de cultivo ya
alteradas por la actividad humana una
vez que encuentra el sitio perfecto se
arranca las alas y crear las dos
protuberancias que establecen su estatus
real después comienza a excavar un túnel
descendente que termina en una cámara
aquí la reina comienza a poner sus
huevos unos diez al día las primeras
larvas nacen a la semana en las tres
semanas siguientes la nueva reina
dependerá de un lote diferente de huevos
sin fertilizar para alimentarse a sí
misma y a su descendencia y en el
proceso perderá la mitad de su peso
corporal
afortunadamente a los 20 días estas
larvas crecerán y darán lugar a la
primera generación de trabajadoras
listas para buscar comida y mantener a
su reducida reina
sus hijas tendrán que trabajar rápido y
devolverle la salud a su madre es
urgente en el área circundante docenas
de reinas vecinas construyen sus propios
ejércitos de hormigas estas colonias han
coexistido pacíficamente hasta ahora
pero una vez aparezcan las obreras
comenzará el fenómeno conocido como
incursión por la progenie las obreras de
los nidos situados a varios metros
comienzan a secuestrar a la progenie de
nuestra reina nuestra colonia toma
represalias pero nuevas colas de
saqueadores procedentes de incluso mayor
distancia aplastan a las obreras
en cuestión de horas los atacantes han
llevado a todo el suministro de crías al
nido de mayor tamaño más cercano y las
hijas de la reina que han sobrevivido la
abandonan buscando su última oportunidad
de sobrevivir la reina sigue el rastro
de las saqueadoras hasta el nido ganador
ahuyenta a otras reinas perdedoras y a
las obreras defensoras del hormiguero y
lucha hasta llegar a lo alto de la pila
de crías las hijas ayudan a su madre a
ganar donde otras reinas fracasan vencen
a la monarca actual y usura la pila de
la progenie con el tiempo el resto de
contrincantes fracasará hasta que sólo
quede una reina y una pila de crías
ahora presidiendo a cientos de obreras
en el gran nido vecino nuestra reina
victoriosa dirige a su colonia hacia su
objetivo principal la reproducción
durante varios años la colonia solo
producirá obreras estériles pero una vez
que la población supere las 23 mil
hormigas cambiará su curso a partir de
ahora cada primavera la colonia
producirá machos y hembras fértiles
alados la colonia produce estas grandes
hormigas a principios del verano y
vuelve a producir obreras en otoño
tras fuertes lluvias las caladas vuelan
hacia el cielo y esparcen los genes de
su reina hasta unos 200 metros a favor
del viento para contribuir a este
frenesí de apareamientos anual la
colonia debe seguir prosperando como un
único súper organismo masivo cada día
las hormigas jóvenes alimentan la reina
y atienden la progenie mientras las
obreras mayores buscan comida y
defienden el nido cuando los intrusos
ataquen estas ancianas guerreras los
aumentarán utilizando venenos después de
cada lluvia la colonia se reúne y usa la
tierra mojada para expandir su nido y si
una inundación desastrosa alcanza su
hogar las hermanas se unen entre sí para
formar una gran balsa viva que lleve a
su reina a salvo
pero por muy fuerte que sea la vida de
una colonia debe terminar tras unos ocho
años nuestra reina se queda sin esperma
y no puede sustituir a las obreras que
mueren la población del hormiguero
disminuye y con el tiempo es derrotada
por una colonia vecina el reinado de
nuestra reina ha acabado pero su legado
genético sigue vivo
apenas ha visto la punta del iceberg de
todas las criaturas extrañas y
excéntricos que habitan el planeta
suscríbase a usted en español para ver
más animaciones sobre el reino animal de
la tierra manténgase conectado y no se
pierda nunca ningún vídeo que valga la
pena compartir